hey it's nearly the end of unlv's fall
semester so what have students learned
so far oh boy I bet quite a bit well
today more than 30 engineering students
are competing in front of a panel of
experts to really jump start their
careers Candace Charles joining us live
at UNLV with a look at some of their
inventions this is awesome Candace good
morning
good morning Heather and John good
morning folks yes it really is awesome
to see what the great mind here the
engineering department are working on
the fall design of project 2022
competition is on and as you can see
there's a lot of different things to
check out it's a chance for the
community to come out here and see what
they've been working on but again it's
also a chance for those great lines to
possibly land their first job and I'm
joined by Molly marks the event the
director here thank you so much for
joining us tell us about some of the
inventions perfect so we've got a total
of 34 participating over 185 students
let's go around which is huge and um
this one particularly what we're
standing by is boxable so they're
looking to solve issues that we have
within our community by creating little
tiny homes that are super easy to put up
cost efficient things like that we have
projects from computer science teams we
have mechanical engineering we have
civil we have entertainment engineering
and design and electrical so we have a
ton of different crazy ideas that these
students have come up with and spent
either 12 weeks working on it or
potentially almost six months so it's a
great exciting time for all of them
they're super stoked and most of them
get to graduate next week so this is
just kind of like that final thing for
them to even win prize money awesome
okay well tell us really quickly about
the judges this one was really cool as
well you guys this is a game that some
of the students have created this is a
team of eight as well yes yes correct
our computer science teams are huge and
so there we have eight to ten team
members and they're just walking around
trying to figure out uh different
aspects of what they can do app wise or
game wise to help us we have 16 judges
awesome some of which have traveled from
different states to come and hang out
with us all day today and they are just
walking around they will be scoring each
team based on different rubric that we
have created and then at the end of the
day I get to figure out all the winners
and we start handing out money I mean
we've had some teams walk away with
three or four thousand dollars because
they've won so many different prize
categories awesome well it sounds like
it's going to be an amazing event not
only for this students for the
University as well as for the community
yeah thank you so much Molly for joining
us this morning bright and early in the
morning we appreciate you you guys can
come on down here and check out the
competition of course we have to cover
all these those on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from UW I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now oh that is so
neat thank you so much Candace